[Music]
[Applause]
phone calls coming up want to check in
with Jeff passon of the mothership he's
at the uh winter meetings and uh
providing reports updates on Sports
Center baseball tonight from Nashville
thanks for joining us Jeff um what is
the directive from show he otani's
people to teams interested in signing
him in free
agency um don't talk about
it did they actually say don't talk I
mean Dave Roberts talked about it yeah
yeah he talked about it and I you know I
hope for the sake of Dave Roberts that
sh Otani goes to the Los Angeles Dodgers
because if ever the question were out
there like did he not go because he
happened to make the grave mistake of
acknowledging that the most money team
in
baseball is
going
after the most moneyfree agen and I you
know when when I look at what the
important things are to show hey Otani
it's going to be winning at the top and
nobody provides a better ability to win
than the Los Angeles Dodgers who year
after year are at top their division and
uh have the highest payrolls and it's
why it's impressive that the Toronto
Blue Jays are in as much as they are in
the Otani sweep Stakes at this point
okay it we weren't sure why Dave Roberts
spoke the Dodger manager but then we
thought maybe maybe he's got Otani maybe
he feels like you know this is a Victory
lap without declaring Victory no no no
no it's not there no okay no no nobody
feels good at this point nobody nobody
knows what's going on the the secretive
nature of this whole thing is um it's
it's just it's I feel like it's a wasted
opportunity forj League Baseball yes we
should be
celebrating and and here's the thing I
think there is a way that shoh Otani can
keep the Privacy that he wants while
leveraging all of the things that exist
in modern society to help both yourself
and baseball and here's what I mean by
that it's not like every time he goes
and visits a team he needs to sit there
and have a press conference and talk
about it and say this and say that all
he has to do is just take a picture in
front of a stadium and people are gonna
go nuts like oh my God he's actually
visiting this team right now it's my
team he
might
and and beyond that the idea be so
2023 when when you have social media
your disposal you have the ability to
leverage a narrative in your favor
unlike anything we have ever seen in
media history and not taking advantage
of that I'm not sure it would get him
paid more it probably would but it
certainly would be the sort of thing
that I think would help baseball and
help Major League Baseball this sport
that has such a a difficult time
permeating the consciousness of uh of
sports in America to do so in the middle
of an NFL season B yeah like that is an
opportunity you're just not going to
find with other players because other
players are not of show heon's
caliber um Satan would you ask Jeff the
poll
question yeah uh today's poll question
we have would you uh paying shoi Otani
500 million plus is either a a smart
investment on and off the field or too
much of a risk with his elbow
issues um a a thousand times B like I
don't know how many people are saying b
um it's it's not just the question about
the elbow right you need to look at
Otani
holistically um let's start here Aaron
judge got $360 million he was a year
older than Otani when he reached free
agency both of them were coming off of
MVP Seasons um so so you can reasonably
say Dan that Otani is in the 300s let's
let's just say 400 million right let's
just say 400 million for the bat alone
okay and I know judge judge plays
defense so it's a little bit different
but I I still don't think it's
unreasonable for 400 million but but the
the money beyond that that he generates
through his oton through the fact that
he is the most popular human being in
the country of Japan so you have this
International aspect and all of the
sponsorship opportunities and everything
that can supercharge you as an
organization financially especially if
you leverage it the right way um I I
mean I'm going to put a small number on
this for what's expected to be a decade
plus long deal let's say it's 100
million right there we're at 500 already
we're at 500 without even factoring in
that he's been
Aion caliber pitcher in the past and
look I have a lot of experience writing
about Tommy John surgery and elbow
issues and I understand that generally
guys who have two Tommy Johns within a
fiveyear
span did not find a whole lot of
long-term when he came over from Japan
was Pres presuming that he's the same as
everyone else he's not he is and this is
not to suggest he is going to
definitively come back and be the
pitcher that he was beforehand I I don't
think anyone knows that at this point
but the idea that we're going to
Discount Otani from doing something
because history tells us others haven't
is a Fool's errand and a mistake that
I'm not going to make
twice what is the time
frame
I get the sense that a choice will
probably be made toward the I guess
we're getting toward the end of this
week around the end of this week and the
the physical process is going to be
something that's very real and very
stringent um you know they're going to
need to do a lot of Imaging you know a
GM who's not involved in the process
that I think Otani is going to live in
the MRI tube whenever you know this is
done because because they they need to
be confident that if they're going out
and giving the biggest contract in North
American Sports history then you know a
a deal that I think in the end is
probably going to be closer to 600
million than it is 500 million if
they're giving that out to the guy then
you know they need every last bit of
confidence that they're not buying
damaged goods or that they don't you
know that something doesn't exist that
they don't know about um so if if that
happens that's probably going to take a
couple of days and you know I I get the
sense that at some point early next week
we're gonna find out what team he's
playing
for uh I wish baseball could celebrate
this it's a shame you know that you know
let let me say this Dan I I feel like by
us talking about this right now it is a
little bit of Celebration and and the
idea that we're putting a damper on this
because of a bad decision to try and
mute people like it's not looking at
what you know we want what it should be
but I'm not going to look at what it is
and lament it to much because we're
gonna have Otani playing somewhere
that's gonna be an unbelievable story
and and still you know he's going to go
out and do his thing and this you know
this offseason that uh has revolved
around him uh Juan stto is very likely
going to get traded today and it's
looking more and more like it's going to
be the New York Yankees um you know
yoshinobu Yamamoto is going to sign
somewhere and it's going to be a
ridiculous frenzy with the Mets and the
Yankees and the Dodgers and the Red Sox
and the Cubs and the Blue Jays and the
Giants I mean all of the big main team
team and big money teams are going to be
in on Yamamoto um I think this is kind
of a cool offseason and is as much as we
wish Otani were something different uh I
just don't want to waste a whole lot of
time my time personally uh sitting there
and saying well what could have been you
know I could have been 63 I'm 5'9 Dan
and it's not great but you know what I
make the best of it with your hair
you're 6 foot but uh Jeff we I I might
be that's fair uh have fun in Nashville
thanks for joining us as
always my apologies for the lateness but
thank you for uh for accommodating time
zones are the worst Jeff pass of the
mothership he's there providing updates
on Sports Center and baseball tonight